democrats in the senate
led of course by bernie sanders and
elizabeth warren
are pushing a draft for the
reconciliation package
that would include 500 billion dollars
that would be collected from fossil fuel
companies
to pay for the admissions that they
spewed out from the years 2000
to 2019. now chuck schumer
for the record has stayed mum on whether
or not he is going to include this 500
billion
fine essentially on fossil fuel
companies to pay for their
uh emissions but why not right
i mean heck one of the big issues we're
having
with this reconciliation bill is oh gee
it's it's very expensive how are we
going to cover the cost
well if it's three and a half trillion
we can pay for that half by putting this
provision
in there the fossil fuel companies
as has been widely reported have known
about the dangers of climate change
since at least the 1970s
i've actually gone through the documents
uh for some reporting
back when i was with desmog blog and
actually they do have documents going
all the way back to the 1950s
where they talk about the fact that we
believe that the burning
that we're doing of these fuels could
possibly be changing the actual
atmosphere
it's remarkable and i know everybody
says that they've known since the 1970s
but if you go through those documents
their internal documents
they've actually been concerned about
this since the 50s it was just really
confirmed for them
in the 70s so either way
they have known about the dangers of
fossil fuel burning they have known what
it does to this planet and yes it is
time
for them to pay us back because these
emissions that go out there these
extreme weather events that we see as a
result of climate change
they cost money they cost lives
and yet instead of making these
industries pay for it we're subsidizing
them to the tune of
i think direct cash subsidies is at 14
billion a year at this point
this is nuts it's time for them to pay
up
and this draft that is not yet in the
reconciliation bill but they want to get
it in the reconciliation bill
but this draft would absolutely
be a great start to get us where we need
to be on this issue